President Trump
is in a post-election funk
as the blue wave that put
Democrats in charge of the House
keeps getting bigger.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As bad as things looked
for Republicans
going into last week's midterms,
Trump himself was apparently
optimistic on election night.
"Vanity Fair" reported
that about 100 friends
and allies
gathered at the White House
for a party
to watch the
midterm election results.
Trump was in high spirits
as the first polls closed,
thinking that perhaps
he'd defied
the laws of political gravity
once again.
"His mood was great,"
one Republican
who spoke with Trump said.
"But that was before
everything went bad."
And you do not want to be
at a party with Donald Trump
when things go bad.
I bet Trump's the kind of guy
who would start the night
at the blender making margaritas
and singing Cardi B...
and, at the end of the night,
crying in the bathtub
eating burgers
with the wrappers still on.
"Why can't you vote, hamburger?"
Of course, early on,
it seemed like Trump
might have good reason
to be in high spirits,
because the narrative
about what was happening
got set very early by the media,
which declared unequivocally
that the election was
definitely not a blue wave.
-When you look at what's
going on here tonight,
this is not a blue wave.
-This is not a blue wave.
-It is not a blue wave.
-It's nothing like a blue wave
or a tidal wave.
-It's not a blue wave.
-So we haven't seen
the blue wave.
-There is not a blue wave.
-That was like two hours in.
Can you imagine if these guys
had been calling
the 1980 Olympics?
-Do you believe in miracles?!
No!
[ Laughter ]
The media rushed
to set a narrative
before most of the results
were actually in,
but now in the week
since the elections,
it's become clear that this
was, in fact, a blue wave.
In fact,
just to give you an idea
of how wrong the media narrative
turned out to be,
take South Carolina, a deep-red
state Trump won by 14 points.
Trump intervened
in the GOP primary
for a South Carolina
Congressional seat
to campaign against the sitting
Republican, Mark Sanford,
a Trump critic.
Sanford famously had an affair
while he was governor,
and when he disappeared,
his initial excuse
was that he was hiking
the Appalachian Trail.
Trump repeatedly mocked Sanford
for that but got the name wrong.
-Never liked him too much.
I wasn't a big fan.
The Tallahassee Trail.
Must be a beautiful place.
Unfortunately,
he didn't go there.
-No, he didn't, because...
there's no such thing.
Tallahassee Trail
sounds like something you'd see
on the price list
at a Florida waxing salon.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So...
So, Trump helped push Sanford
out in favor of Katie Arrington,
a Republican who ran
as a staunch Trump ally.
Now, remember, this is a seat
that has been held by
Republicans since the '80s.
Let's see how Trump's
handpicked
Republican candidate did.
-The Democratic candidate,
Joe Cunningham,
defeated Republican
Katie Arrington.
It's a surprising upset
in a district
that favored President Trump
by double digits in 2016.
And it's a seat held by
a Republican for four decades.
-Damn!
No wonder Trump's depressed.
When he heard that, he probably
stormed out of the White House
screaming, "If anyone needs me,
I'll be hiking
the Tallahassee Trail!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump couldn't even get a
close ally elected in a district
that's been held by Republicans
for four decades
in a deep-red state
he won by 14 points.
And as the reality
of the blue wave
has come into focus
over the last week,
Trump has apparently been
in a post-election funk.
One administration official said
the President has lashed out
at several aides,
from junior press assistants
to senior officials.
He's also fighting
with American allies
like French President
Emmanuel Macron.
For two years, Trump has been
desperate to be Macron's friend,
at one point even brushing
dandruff off of his shoulder.
-We do have
a very special relationship.
In fact, I'll get that
little piece of dandruff off.
It'll be...
We have to make him perfect.
He is perfect.
-Dude. Play it cool.
You can tell Trump
has never had adult friends.
Because as soon as he finds one,
he starts grooming him
like a capuchin monkey.
"You want to eat a bug
from my hair?"
Well, after the midterms,
their budding bromance
immediately started to cool off
when an angry and sullen Trump
decided to lash out at France
over trade,
specifically targeting one of
France's most iconic exports.
-This is what he said.
He said on trade,
"France makes excellent wine,
but so does the U.S.
The problem is that France
makes it very hard for the U.S.
to sell its wines into France
and charges big tariffs,
whereas the U.S. makes it easy
for French wines
and charges very small tariffs.
Not fair. Must change."
-"Not fair. Must change."
You know, it's very hard to
come off as an expert on wine
when you talk like Frankenstein.
"Aroma good.
Body full.
Fire bad."
And, dude, you're picking
a fight with France over wine?
We have no chance.
One of their most famous wines
is a Bordeaux,
called Grand Cru Classé,
made by a vineyard
called the Chateau Latour.
One of our most famous wines
is a box with a spout
sticking out of it.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
So, why --
Why is Trump lashing out
at everyone?
Well, in particular, that he --
I'm sorry.
So, why --
So, why is Trump lashing out
at everyone, question mark?
Wally just pointed at
the question mark for me.
[ Laughter ]
Do you want to --
Wally, you want to bring
the card around
and show everybody
how squeezed up
that question mark is?
Show them.
Come on, Wally.
Bring me the card.
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
[ Applause ]
You wonder why I got that wrong.
Look at Wally.
Look where Wally
put that question mark.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter continues ]
Just use another card.
[ Laughter ]
So, why is Trump
lashing out at everyone?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
In your defense, Wally,
the "why" should've
given it away, as well.
[ Laughter ]
Well, in particular,
he's depressed over the prospect
that Democrats will now
use their subpoena power
in the House to investigate
everything from his tax returns
to his bank records.
He's spent two years
making enemies
in the Democratic caucus,
and now, those enemies
will have tremendous power.
Just take California
Congresswoman Maxine Waters,
who has been the subject
of Trump's racist insults
for months and especially in the
closing days of the election.
-I watch this Maxine Waters.
You ever seen Maxine Waters?
[ Audience murmuring ]
A low I.Q. individual.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Low I.Q.
Many of these
Democrat politicians
who are really disciples
of a very low I.Q. person,
Maxine Waters.
Your new de facto leader
of the Democrat party,
the legendary Maxine Waters.
Legendary?
Leave it to Trump to think
he's insulting someone
by giving them
a kick-ass nickname.
[ Laughter ]
"The Legendary Maxine Waters"
sounds like something
Angela Bassett
would win an Oscar for.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Trump decided --
Trump decided to spend two years
making Maxine Waters
his arch nemesis.
And now
it looks like that decision
has come back to bite him.
But I mean, really,
how bad could it be?
What's the worst that
Maxine Waters could do to Trump?
-Maxine Waters,
who won re-election Tuesday,
will likely take over
as the chairperson
of the House Financial Services
committee.
Waters, a vocal critic of Trump,
could have power to subpoena
the president's tax returns.
-Damn!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Damn. She can subpoena his tax
returns, his bank records.
Hell, she can subpoena
the results of his I.Q. test.
[ Laughter ]
Trump has probably been calling
her every day for a week
like a sleazy Hollywood agent
trying to make it up
with a client.
"Maxine, baby, this is all one
big misunderstanding.
When I said low I.Q.,
I meant high I.Q.
And when I said I.Q.,
I meant "iconic queen."
You are an iconic queen.
Slay.
Slay, Queen, slay."
[ Laughter ]
"Please don't
subpoena my tax returns!"
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
But as much --
[ Cheers and applause ]
As much focus as there is
on investigating Trump,
one of the keys
to the Democrats' success
is that they ran on an agenda
focused on issues
like healthcare.
And now they'll have the power
to pass bills in the House,
like Medicare for all
and force Republicans
to take positions on them.
And that has right-wing
Fox News pundits
like Laura Ingraham
freaking out.
-Fresh-faced
congressional members
descended on the Capitol
for orientation today.
Congresswoman-elect
Rashida Tlaib, Ilhan Omar,
Ayanna Pressley,
and Ocasio-Cortez,
they represent some of the most
radical views in Congress.
Free college for all.
Free healthcare for all.
The abolishment of ICE.
A green new deal,
where the U.S. depends entirely
on renewable energy.
-Wait. They're trying to scare
us with free healthcare?
[ Laughter ]
You know an idea is popular
when even Fox News
can't make it sound bad.
"What's next?
These radical socialists
are proposing crazy new ideas
like free pizza,
a trunk full of gold,
'Hamilton' tickets,
a kiss from Ryan Gosling!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump knows that he'll be held
accountable for his actions
for the first time in two years,
and as a result, he's panicking.
A week after the midterms,
it's clear that we saw
a blue wave and a national
repudiation of his presidency,
with Democrats winning
everywhere from the coast
to the Midwest to the...
-Tallahassee Trail.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]